[Musique]
bonsoir décès lors d'auditions publiques
en direct comme tous les lundis soir
pendant une heure sur lcp assemblée
nationale public sénat et avec le figaro
est notre invité aujourd'hui et jean
baptiste djebbari bonjour bonsoir vous
êtes secrétaire d'état aux transports
merci d'être sur ce plateau où vont se
succéder je vous rappelle les règles du
jeu tam traduit de public sénat
j'ai deux bouchées de rcp et puis en
duplex tout à l'heure qui dialogueront
avec vous une sénatrice mathilde de
panneaux vice-présidente du groupe la
france un soumise à l'assemblée
nationale député du val de marne et jean
raymond hugonnet qui est sénateur et
l'air de l'essonne ils vous parleront
par exemple du plan de relance entre
autres pas seulement 1
et puis pour conclure tout à l'heure
nous rejoindre à yves thréard qui est
directeur adjoint et organiste figaro
parce qu'il ya aussi plein de choses à
dire sur l'avenir du gouvernement
parfait première question d'abord je
vous parlais du permis de conduire parce
qu'on parle beaucoup des jeunes qui sont
en difficulté en ce moment et il se
trouve que ça remonte beaucoup on le
voit il y a du retard dans l'examen du
permis de conduire parfois trois mois de
retard avant de passer son examen de
permis de conduire parce que tout a été
arrêté pendant la crise du coronavirus
est ce que vous allez résoudre ça
comment ça va se passer
un petit and yet de problème il ya le
problème des jeunes et le problème des
poids lourds est en fait on a été alerté
sur ces deux sujets et on a agi depuis
le début mai pour commencer à reprendre
les cours de conduite et depuis fin mai
la reprise effective des examens de
conduite pour les poids lourds et remise
en route et depuis le 8 juin pour les
permis b donc pour les jeunes les choses
sur les voitures ou les voitures les
choses se déroulent depuis juin on a
donné aussi quelques flexibilités
notamment pour les examinateurs qui
puisse conduire un examen le soir et le
samedi matin c'est n'était pas possible
jusqu'à présent trois mois de liste
d'attenté c'est ça qu'on essaie
d'accélérer donner la flexibilité on est
vraiment pas mal de jeunes retraités
jeunes inspecteurs et l'examinateur
retraités qui reviennent pour un temps
et pour aider effectivement à écluser ce
serait bien mais est-ce que vous pensez
que ce stock de trois mois va être
excusez dans quelques semaines avec le
sujet c'est qu'on a un protocole
sanitaire qui a fait baisser et c'est
normal pour des raisons évidemment de
sécurité sanitaire qui a fait baisser le
nombre d'examens par jour et il est pas
allégé il est un peu allégés on revient
d'ailleurs quasiment au niveau d'avant
qu'ovide on avait très examen par jour
en gros par examinateurs on est descendu
à 11 on revient aujourd'hui à peu près à
13 donc vous voyez qu'on reprend un
rythme normal
mais vous avez raison de dire qu'il ya
encore quelques que j'espère que les
j'espère que les mesures de flexibilité
que nous avons pris sûrement suffisante
sinon nous n'hésiterons pas à accélérer
encore les choses alléger encore plus
vite c'est ça que nous devons d'avoir
voté zago lire à alléger plus vite oui
bien sûr et nous avons voté dans la loi
mobilité il ya maintenant quasiment une
grosse année nous allons voter des
dispositifs qui permettent de
dématérialiser les demandes bref qui
donne beaucoup de flexibilité côté
visage et côté candidats et nous allons
voir comment accélérer tout ça parce que
les décrets ne sont pas encore tout à
fait pris sur le sujet alors justement
rapidement vous avez un jeune qui va
passer son permis de conduire il attend
depuis trois mois est ce que vous pouvez
lui dire là bas d'ici l'été
tu pourras passer son permis de conduire
bon c'est difficile de faire promesses
promesses là maintenant à ce jeune
virtuel mais ce que je dis c'est quelque
chose sont revenus à la vitesse normale
donc il n'y a pas de retard qui va qui
vont se cumuler
et par ailleurs nous avons des
flexibilités je vous invite donc à se
reporter quand c'est possible il ya
certaines régions qui expérimentent
pense notamment à l'occitanie qui
expérimente des les plateformes de
candidature dématérialisée je l'invite à
se rapprocher dans ce cas là des
services d des agences et des autres
écoles de manière à pouvoir accélérer
pour lui le processus de passage de
l'examen pratique qui vous êtes
optimiste ça va se résorber bis mais
comme comme pour toute activité
économique sociale das est assuré pour
ces jeunes qui doivent reprendre des
perles des cours d'auto école
parfaitement conscient raison pour
laquelle y compris d'ailleurs dans la
loi mobilité nous avons inscrit des
mesures pour vous savez alléger le coût
des formations cassé mon le diminuer de
moitié
c'est environ 1600 1700 euros le coût
d'un permis avec l'objectif de diminuer
de moitié
donc ce sont des choses nous avons
évidemment en tête et à coeur on va
accueillir maintenant thème traduit de
public sénat
sur table bonsoir francis sommes bonsoir
jean baptiste djebbari on va commencer
par parler des transports franciliens
qui a accusé bien des pertes de recettes
très conséquente à la suite de la
pandémie deux milliards 600 millions
d'euros selon valérie pécresse matin
vous avez dit que l'état serait aux
côtés de la région ile-de-france mais
vous promettez pour l'instant seulement
430 millions d'euros
le compte n'y est pas pour la présidente
de la région elle vous a répondu depuis
cela chahut j'ai eu cette discussion à
l'envi avec vérité crès toute la semaine
dernière ce que nous avons fait
aujourd'hui enfin demain puisque en
l'occurrence et laurent saint martin le
rapporteur général du budget qui portera
cette mesure c'est que nous alignons le
dispositif pour la région de france qui
sera le même le dispositif de soutien
qui sera le même que pour toutes les
autres régions françaises
c'est à dire un acompte sur ce qu'on
appelle le versement mobilité sur la
partie fiscale la perte fiscale
et comme nous appliquons les mêmes
règles cela fait 4 135 millions d'euros
après nous avons la discussion sur le
montant avec madame pécresse elle dit 2
milliards 6 mai 2000 ercis et à van les
économies de coûts avant l'effet tva
quoi revient alors prouver geste
commercial que notamment elle a fait au
nom de la région et c'est plutôt autour
de 1 milliards 7,1 milliards 8 les
chiffres sur lesquels nous arrivons nous
aurons ces discussions avec elles sur
les chiffres mais moitié moins un
milliard ça tombe bien vite 430 millions
ça oui mais comme toutes les régions ça
fait quand même un quart de la somme est
pareil j'ai dit à madame pécresse qui a
été une partenaire efficace pour la
gestion des transports en ile de france
je veux le dire parce que pas de sujet
entre nous mais je lui ai expliqué il
n'y a pas de sujets politiques derrière
votre refus de compenser les pertes et
nous compensons phase par phase l'idée
c'est que la région puisse payer la ratp
la sncf pour la quote-part pour
notamment le mois de juillet et août ce
qui sera possible et l'état s'y est
engagé et moi je voulais dit ce matin je
le redis à votre micro il n'y aura pas
d'arrêt des transports au delà du 10
juillet en ile-de-france comme cela a pu
parfois avez vous évalué à 1 milliard
sept vous parce que les faits sont réels
ils lui disent eh oui oui les murs un
passage si on compte pas évidemment les
ristournes qu'a fait madame pécresse ça
veut là c'est un petit tacle non les
gestes commerciaux gestes commerciaux
crois qu'elle ans qui sont des gestes
politiques ils sont en 2d mais qui sont
parfaitement ses commerciaux
remboursement du passe navigo sait
parfaitement mais qui sont parfaitement
d incompréhensible c'est parfaitement de
la compétence les régions et
qu'effectivement ce qui les fonds
doivent assumer il nous reste
moi que s'agissant à la fois des pertes
de recettes tarifaires
elle est la compensation du versement
mobilité jouent les 10 à madame pécresse
et elle le sait et assure à ses côtés
mais de manière simultanée avec tout ce
qui est remboursement du passif social
qui doit le prendre en charge les gestes
commerciaux font partie des politiques
qui sont à la main des régions donc ça
vous regarde pas c'est pas que c'est un
homme regarde je veux dire c'est pas
vous qui allez penser oui je rejette pas
là je veux pas botter en touche parce
qu'il ya un sujet de fond sur les
recettes tarifaires on peut penser
qu'avec le télétravail on aura peut-être
cette annonce cette année - j'en aurai
transports en commun mais peut-être
l'année prochaine
à peine moins jeunes devraient être en
cornouailles est peut-être encore
l'année d'après et donc moi je vraiment
juste peut être qu'on regarde ça d'un
oeil totalement lucide avec madame
pécresse avec les autres présidents de
région ce que nous faisons pour regarder
quelle est la dynamique aussi deux
reprises dans les transports en commun
et nous n'éluderons aucune question
qu'elle reçoit et ya pas de francs il
rassuré oui effectivement il n'ya pas
que l'ile-de-france le manque lié aux
qu'ovide aux transports publics pour les
collectivités est estimé à 4 milliards
d'euros au total
donc c'est à ça que vous faites
référence il va y avoir une mesure
inscrite dans le budget dans le numéro 3
demain absolument il ya une mesure de
compensation
donc c'est du versement mobilité la
partie fiscale qui n'est pas qui n'a pas
été pas subis notamment par les
autorités organisatrices et
singulièrement par les régions et donc
nous appliquons les mêmes règles de
calcul le même dispositif de soutien
pour cet acompte du versement mobilité
pour l'ensemble des régions qui sera
effectivement inscrits demain par le
rapporteur général du budget laurent
samantha pourquoi vous ne faites pas
comme de très nombreux pays européens
qui pour le coup qu'on pense
l'intégralité des pertes pour les
transports publics collectifs
d'abord c'est pas tout à fait vrai que
les tous les pays européens feront plus
tard
non mais c'est pas tout à fait vrai et
ne croyez moi nous observons de très
près ce que fait londres ce qu'a fait
l'allemagne humeur générale ce que fait
le micro le métro de rome 2000 ans donc
voilà la france fera selon le modèle
français nous avons le réseau le plus
dense et 2 très loin des métros les plus
denses au monde et donc nous prendrons
sujet par sujet nous compenserons ce que
nous avons à compenser nous le ferons
toute transparence avec les régions et
elles le savent et ça sera pas à 100%
gamme vous avez dit ce matin justement
que 100% des trains
vous roulez dès le week-end je vous
propose de regarder une photo une photo
qui a été appris sur le toulouse
perpignan le voir c'est bon là voici
cette photo avec ses passagers qui
s'entassent on voit aussi des photos
avec des quais bondés
est-ce que vous assumez et maquillés
100% de ses trains et que ce soit dans
ce type de conditions là voilà deux
choses
l'idée on est dans une phase de
déconfinement de reprise des activités
et nous avons toujours cherché à avoir
plus de trains que de fréquentation ce
qui est le cas aujourd'hui nous avons
quasiment 100% des trains partout
maintenant et nous avons 50 % de la
fréquentation en province un peu moins
sur le réseau ile-de-france mais vous
voyez c'est une association quand même à
ce que celui-ci a aussi des reprises
il ya aussi des reprises notamment au
moment des heures de pointe parce que
les activités reprennent là pour aider
aussi sur le billet à un euro
oui parce que la région avait fait une
promotion hors de france voilà à vous
engager pour un euro et il ya aussi
cette photo que vous avez présenté il ya
aussi le port du masque qui est sur
cette photo parfaitement respecté et moi
je le dis et je le dis parce que c'est
une réalité
d'abord les transports en commun sont
faits pour transporter en masse des
personnes qui se rendent pour un
transport du quotidien nous avons essayé
sur toute la chaîne du voyage de mettre
le maximum de sécurité sanitaire
ça a été évidemment au départ mais
tellement des heures de pointe le port
du masque obligatoire très bien respecté
toutes les procédures de nettoyage de
désinfection qui sont faites dans les
ter dans les bus dans les métros partout
en france et c'est très bien fait et
donc vous assumez ce type d'image mais
si vous voulez bien non mais ils sont
protégés par le masque même si c'est
bondé vous l'assumez s'est pas d'abord
c'est pas tout à fait bondée il ya de
l'affluence mais il a une influence qui
est en heure de pointe je ne sais pas
quelle horreur cette photo a été prise
maintenant de pointer est quelque chose
d'assez régulier dans les thés verts
dans les métros et nous aurons ce type
d'image
oui je l'assumé vous savez que l'idée
que nous avons c'est de permettre aux
marques notamment d'être la pierre
angulaire de la protection dans les
transports et je constate encore une
fois justement que le port du masque est
très bien c'est justement parlons du
port du masque cette fois dans les
avions
oui on va parler du port du masque dans
les avions quand vous prenez un avion
d'air france par exemple on vous demande
un masque chirurgical un masques à usage
unique
or le gouvernement espagnol une hache et
qui était à votre place il ya deux
semaines préconise l'utilisation de
masques grand public en tissu est ce
qu'il ya un problème
une contradiction il ya une première
phase du déconfinement qui s'est fait
d'un transport aérien d'abord sur la
base de règles européennes et là
effectivement été décidé du fait des
particularités du secteur aérien du fait
aussi de la reprise très progressive du
trafic d'avoir des masques chirurgicaux
c'est une doctrine qui sera peut-être
amené à évoluer en lien avec notamment
il faut que ça a évolué que les choses
auraient voulu vous avez bien vu contre
le 11 mai et 2 juin on a eu toute une
phase de déconfinement très progressif
avec les trafics qui sont restés très
modestes notamment s'agissant du trafic
aérien
là nous avons une deuxième phase qui va
s'ouvrir avec eux depuis 15 juin avec la
reprise et voilà trash schengen nous
aurons une troisième phase avec la
reprise des vols internationaux et
d'ailleurs nous sommes en train entre
pays européens de catégoriser sur le
plan sanitaire les différents pays dont
vous voyez que les normes les
prescriptions les mesures sanitaires où
elles vont évoluer en sens vous entends
mais imaginez vous êtes passager
je peux témoigner j'en viens vous avez
un masque en tissu et vous arrivez aux
portes de l'avion vous dis bah non c'est
un masque chirurgical qu'est ce que vous
ne comprenez plus rien mais ce qui se
passe notamment pour prendre ce qu'elle
a et en france j'ai eu l'occasion d'en
parler avec eux encore avant-hier matin
il me dit qu'effectivement notamment au
départ il y avait environ 25 % des gens
qui arrivent avec des masques qui
n'était pas chirurgicaux ils en ont
donné ils en ont distribué en masque
d'appoint de manière à ce que le wef
déroule bien ou noyer les choses se font
en bonne intelligence avec les opéras
qui a pas de problème c'est moi qui ai
pas de problème c'est qu'il ya une
solution inédite particulière et que
quand il ya des problèmes ou des
dysfonctionnements ou des difficultés
l'ensemble de la chaîne les opérateurs
les exploitants aéroportuaire six mètres
pour que le voyage se déroule à propos
de main des conditions y en a pas un qui
est bien sûr que l'autre de masques je
suis pas expert en masquer en rien au
foot masculin mais je sais que les
masques chirurgicaux sont très
protecteurs raison pour laquelle ils
sont il est 15h unique c'est souvent
plus sûr alors sur les masques
obligatoire dans les transports publics
ce matin vous avez dit que certainement
il restera obligatoire jusqu'à la fin de
l'été au même moment
elisabeth borgne a dit elle jusqu'à fin
novembre
alors quel est le bon calendrier lorsque
j'ai dit l'humeur générale depuis assez
longtemps c'est que et c'est un
consensus je crois scientifique sur la
question c'est que le masque est utile
évidemment tant que le virus est actif
et circulant et aujourd'hui il est actif
circulant aprilia qu'effectivement ce
cas des visas mais de bandes est tout à
fait raison il ya un cadre légal qui
sera posée puisque vous savez que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire sera plongée du 10
juillet
au 10 novembre quatre mois plus tard et
donc effectivement les murs et un état
d'urgence sanitaire qui se poursuit
jusqu'au 10 novembre en tout cas il y
aura des mesures
il y aura des mesures qui permettront
enfin l'état d'urgence sanitaire
s'arrête mais certaines mesures et
notamment le port du masque transport
peut-être considérer comme des mesures
qui vont perdurer jusqu ou plus tard en
tout cas en l'état du droit
quatre mois après l'arrêt des violences
et n'était donc je n'ouvrais ce sera
évidemment réévalué sera évalué par ceux
qui savent les autorités sanitaires
scientifique en fonction de la virulence
du virus de l'apparition ou non que ce
tome vous avez parlé de cet été ce matin
parce que vous étiez plus optimistes
alors non parce que je pense que cet été
d'abord il ya une demande de la part des
usagers pour l'été d'avoir le port du
masque parce qu'il considère que c'est
un élément d'unification personnalité et
rassurant les opérateurs le souhaitent
et beaucoup d'élus le souhaite donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé de cet été
ça me semble normal ou voire souhaitable
de poser un cadre qui soit qu'ils soient
connus et qui soit rassurant pour ceux
qui auront à voyager cet été ils seront
nombreux puisque nous avons déjà 35 %
des réservations sur les tgv plage y
être un jour à ce jour cette annonce a
augmenté très vite ces derniers jours et
c'était 20% la semaine dernière 35 pour
cent cette semaine c'est en retrait par
rapport à la haine à -30% par rapport à
l'année dernière mais ça veut dire qu'il
va y avoir des pertes à 200 ch une
dernière question là dessus
et oui le barça à la sncf 4 milliards de
pertes pour la sncf dû à la pandémie
auxquels il faut ajouter le milliard qui
est dû aux grèves de fin 2019
vous allez aider la sncf à quelle
hauteur
d'abord la sncf a été soutenu pendant la
pandémie puisque vous savez que nous en
ont pris quasiment cent dix mille
salariés la sncf au chômage partiel
la sncf bénéficie de contributions
publiques chaque année je le rappelle
parce que souvent on oublie dans des
baies pluie mais tout de même lâché 15
milliards chaque année que l'état
demandera et nous sommes en train n'y a
pas de sujet de trésorerie immédiat pour
la sncf elle s'est refinancée et on sait
très bien que jusqu'en septembre octobre
prochain on a pas de sujet de cessation
de paiement des fournisseurs ou de
l'activité intérieure comme ça nous ne
conduisons ces travaux que jean pierre
farandou que j'ai très régulièrement au
téléphone que je vois très régulièrement
on aura des échéances avec des conseils
d'administration qui vont se tenir fin
du mois début du mois prochain et les
choses seront clarifiées à ce moment là
ont bien évidemment que les services de
merci et je les dis l'etat sera aux
côtés évidemment de la sncf pour aborder
la suite avec beaucoup d'ambition pour
le mode ferroviaire
merci dame merci francis on va faire un
détour maintenant par le fugueur live et
c'est vincent roux qu'on retrouve
bonsoir vincent vais le dire vous ce qui
circule sur le figaro live et sur les
réseaux sociaux de votre côté qu'est ce
qu'elle est le thème qui ressort alors
parmi les thèmes qui ressorte c'est
parmi les articles les plus commentés
sur le site du figaro bonsoir monsieur
le ministre sur le secrétaire d'état il
y a ce qui concerne la proposition de
réduire la vitesse sur les autoroutes à
110 km/heure propositions faites par la
convention citoyenne sur le climat qui a
rendu ses travaux et approuvé par
plusieurs ministres dont votre ministre
de tutelle et d'isabelle bord alors il
ya des commentaires je vous en vivant
quelques-uns je crois qu'il faut
absolument valider tout cela par
référendum ce n'est pas possible que 150
personnes décident pour l'ensemble des
français c'est totalement fou autre
commentaire celui de david les écolos
vont bientôt proposé de remettre en
service les diligences à cheval pour
réduire la pollution et des accidents
dus à la vitesse et guerbert qui nous
dit on pourrait limiter à 110 en
périurbain
là où il ya beaucoup de circulation mais
c'est déjà le cas la plupart du temps il
faudrait surtout le faire appliquer et
laisser ailleurs la vitesse actuelle qui
finalement concernera un trafic modéré
et vous qu'en pensez-vous jean baptiste
djebbari gens pensent que comme des buts
et j'ai déjà vécu les 80 kilomètres
heure
c'était un traumatisme et non mais
c'était une leçon en quelque sorte parce
que je me rappelle très bien quoi
circonscription donc la haute vienne
plutôt un territoire rural plutôt un
territoire où la voiture et voyez là le
moyen de transport principal
si tu as très bien que les discussions
étaient non seulement des discussions
d'ordre écologique
certains croyaient ou pas dans la
capacité pour cette mesure d'être
efficace sur le plan de la pollution ou
la moindre pollution
c'est aussi un débat sur la sécurité
routière certains disaient ça n'a aucun
intérêt parce qu'on fait des accidents
ne se font pas là mais sur les routes
nationales etc etc
et puis certains disaient c'est un sujet
de liberté individuelle aux libertés
publiques vous restreignez notre liberté
et c est en fait en entendant ça je me
dis que dans le moment que nous
connaissons actuellement
cette même ses dimensions existent
également
raison pour laquelle moi je me suis
exprimé ce matin je pense que c'est un
beau sujet si jamais le président
choisissait de porter un référendum sur
une série de propositions qui par
ailleurs ne sont pas les ressorts de la
loi je trouve que ça ferait partie des
beaux sujets de société parce qu'en fait
sous une mesure qui paraît un peu
administrative est un peu technique
il ya beaucoup de sujets alors
démocratique à 7 pour isabelle borne a
dit qu'à titre personnel elles étaient
favorables aux 110 km/heure et vous à
titre personnel mais moi je pense qu'on
a cité la question de vincent mon avis
pour ça n'intéresse absolument personne
aussi mais c'est quoi une campagne
électorale s'il ya un référendum tous
les avis compte
moi donc je voterai si un référendum
j'ai bien comme citoyen mais vous feriez
vous le voyez je pense que dans ce
moment là où on a eu une intuition du
président de la république
une convention assez inédite dans sa
forme de beaux débats démocratiques et
où le président aura à s'exprimer
notamment peut-être au-delà du 29 juin
quand ils rentrent chez la convention
sur les suites qu'il entendait donner
mais pourquoi ça vous jette de ça me
gêne c'est sur 110 ou 130
kilomètres/heure this is it est un sujet
tabou et gênant moi ça me gêne pas du
tout alors le jour où j'aurai à voter je
voudrais bien du sirpa terre
le jour où on aura même comme si tu es e
explosif j'essaie d'expliquer la
complexité du sujet et moi j'ai explosif
j'ai porté par exemple km heure comme
député à l'époque donc je vois
parfaitement à quoi ça correspond est ce
que ça peut générer comme comme comme
des bas comme effusions et vous n'avez
pas envie que ça recommence nan parce
que non mais je pense que le moment que
nous connaissons est un moment
démocratique intéressant et inédit avec
un exercice démocratie française peut
s'honorer et que le président de la
république qui reçoit les conventionnels
le 29 juin prochain aura toute latitude
pour lire la suite alors on saura pas ce
soir petit assez gênants comme sujet
comme moi ça me gêne pas du tout et ne
s'agite pas un bon moment c'est un
moment complexe c'est beaucoup plus avec
toute l'expérience que vous avez deviné
d'évoquer on pourrait imaginer de vous
dire eh ben oui moi je suis plutôt pour
plutôt qu'aux autres voilà moi je crois
que ça n'intéresse personne
quelques 2 il avait ce genre de passions
françaises à la sucrerie d'antan leur
disent même ça mais je suis je pense
qu'il faut laisser les choses se
dérouler la convention a rendu ses
conclusions le présenter à un public
recevra s'exprimer et dire à la suite
c'est lui qui était à l'initiative des
parents vincent désolé
donc voilà on a le sentiment en a le
sentiment qu'on ne fait pas taire d'état
a à titre personnel est plutôt fava des
papes favorable aux 110 kilomètres heure
mais que le secrétaire d'état aux
transports ne peux pas le dire
on a le sentiment d'une jeune il ya une
frustration pour les jeunes dernier
parce que vous n'arrivez pas à me faire
accoucher d'une réponse sociale alors on
va t'en merci vincent d'avoir essayé en
tout cas est mal et on accueille
président bush et de lcp
bonjour rigide ou bonsoir bonsoir
francis rang saint-jean-baptiste et
djebbari la convention citoyenne pour le
climat a été créé en réponse au gilet
jaune qui s'opposaient on se souvient à
la taxe carbone dans les propositions
qui ont été remises à elisabeth demande
il n'est plus question de cette taxe
carbone pourquoi est ce qu'elle est
définitivement enterrée je crois que la
convention avait décidé d'écarter le
sujet au motif que peut-être il était
trop politique
en tout cas ils donneraient lustres et
rod rodez bat rodez mois à l'inter de la
convention il nous semble qu'ils ont
choisi eux mêmes de d'évacuer ce sujet
pour se concentrer sur d'autres sujets
très large part de caravanes c'est
terminé on n'en parle plus parce que
dans le cadre de la commencer deux sets
ce débat-là a été écarté du récit lieu
quelques autres débats qui n'ont pas été
tenues sur l'énergie sur le nucléaire
quelques débats qui souvent agite les
débats autour de la tête pour y revenir
la taxe carbone vous demandez mais je
pense que procédons en séquences nous
avons cette convention citoyenne nous
aurons avant des mesures qui sont
aujourd'hui sur la table nous aurons le
plaisir d'un public va s'exprimer sur le
sujet qui dira ce qu'il entend faire et
au moment du débat budgétaire je ne
doute pas que ces sujets de taxe carbone
reviendront par voie parlementaire dans
le cadre du débat politique mais prenons
les choses par séquences
en l'état la convention n'en a pas fait
alors en revanche beaucoup et il ya eu
des propositions qui consiste à abaisser
la tva de 10 à 5,5 pour cent sur les
billets de train est ce que vous vous y
être favorables voici une proposition
dès lors qu'il existe dans le débat
parlementaire depuis assez longtemps
l'allemagne l'a fait la critique il est
fait sur ses propositions en général
c'est que les baisses de tva ne profite
pas aux usagers or s'il y avait une
baisse de tva il fallait qu'elle profite
aux usagers c'est en général assez
d'ailleurs compliquée à évaluer parce
que vous savez qu y compris
sncf les autres opérateurs pratique soit
l'appel le revenu malade humaine
c'est-à-dire qu'ils adaptent le prix du
billet en fonction de la demande
donc il faut regarder tout ça cette
mesure est connu il faudra la faire
cette baisse si jamais il devait être
prise si elle devait être faite cette
baisse il faudra qu'elle profite au
consommateur serait qu'elles soient
répercutées sur le consommateur
répercutera dimanche c'est un organe
doit pourquoi pas vous dites mais ça
mais quand même une forme
d'administration des prix vous savez que
la loi en france la liberté tarifaire
donc il faut regarder tout ça ce sont
des sujets encore une fois mais pourquoi
pas parce que si je vous entends vous
dis qu à bahreïn le fait pourquoi pas
dans l'esprit je partage l'esprit et si
effectivement le prix des billets baisse
c'est une chose plutôt favorable au
consommateur je partage cette il faut
que le prix du billet paissent dans le
hot proposition la suppression des
lignes aériennes quand le trajet peut
être fait en moins de quatre heures vous
vous aviez un train moins de 2h30 en
train est ce que vous pensez que c'est
souhaitable 24 heures en train supprimé
lignes aériennes manière générale le
sujet sous jacent c'est l'aménagement du
territoire d'abord parce que vous avez
raison de dire que en dessous de deux
heures et demie notamment s'agissant du
groupe air france et nous avons dit que
si jamais la france se retirer de
certaines des lignes alors d'autres
opérateurs ne pourrait pas y venir ça
c'est un engagement d'équité notamment
pour le groupe la france
mais au delà de quatre heures et moi je
ne tranche pas cette mesure aujourd'hui
mais où les quatre heures vous aurez le
grand massif central des villes comme
limoges comme bribes comme casse comme
aurillac comme clermont ferrand qui
n'ont pas aujourd'hui d'alternative
ferroviaire vraiment robuste aller à
limoges chez 3h30 de train avec beaucoup
de retard beaucoup de travaux et je le
sais parce que j'ai souvent fait ce
trajet encore récemment sa pouzin ça
posera forcément une question de
l'attractivité des territoires
l'installation des entreprises et je
sais ce que diront les élus moi je dis
qu'est ce qu'ils diront les élus ont que
ce sont des territoires qu'il ya une
france à deux vitesses est calé
territoire qui vont être oublié si
jamais cette mesure là et fait donc sa
valeur à la crise des gilets jaunes
finalement non mais je détiens révélé
ces territoires dits écologiques
importants s'est adjugé d'aménagement du
territoire c'est un sujet de
l'attractivité de certaines villes
françaises qui ont vocation à toujours
vouloir vous vous dites élus locaux ne
laisseront pas le dire que ce sont des
mesures qui nécessitent d'être débattue
territorialement par ceux qui sont
concernés par la mesure oui entre la
mesure présentée dans sa vertu
écologique qui est réel il ya aussi la
réalité des territoires et que nous
devons entendre ces voix loi ces voiles
à part
sous peine de créer ou de recréer ça
doit être négocié territoire par
territoire exactement ça va être
concertés négocier et mise en oeuvre
territoire par territoire et par
ailleurs san bon ça n'empêche vous vous
dites ordinaires en france mais ce sera
également interdit aux autres opérateurs
c'est ce que vous venez de dire est ce
que vous pensez que bruxelles laissera
faire ça m'a d'abord nous sommes
évidemment regardé la conformité de
certaines mesures de restriction par
rapport au droit européen et je vous
confirme que les services mais ça va
nous disent me disent qu'il est possible
effectivement part ça rentre dans le
réglementaire notamment pour des
dimensions environnementales d'empêcher
alors qu'une opérateurs se retire un
autre opérateur aérien pour le coup de
venir s'y implanter cela me thorel
distinction en l'occurrence en tout cas
l'air sur cette décision là il y aurait
pas de distorsion de concurrence
en tout cas l'analyse juridique nous
faisons elle sera évidemment j'imagine
débattu et challenge et par certains
avant d'être avant d'être ministre vous
avez été dans l'aviation d'affaires
si on prend l'exemple par exemple d'un
d'un chef d'entreprise qui doit faire du
business à marseille qui vient de madrid
madrid paris paris marseille tout cela
en avion ça se connectent bien voilà ça
va assez vite et pour rentrer le soir à
madrid
s'il doit prendre le train ça change
tout pour lui il peut peut-être pas le
faire dans la journée ça va lui coûter
plus cher
finalement est-ce que vous n'avez pas
peur que l'on perde un peu de
rayonnement économique
une des parties du sujet et d'heures
dans l'engagement que nous avons demandé
à la france et de se retirer sur les
lignes qui sont les lignes directes
notamment qui vont vers orly et qu'ils
ne rejoignent pas le hub de roissy parce
qu'effectivement il ya une partie ne
rejoigne pas l'international même pas
des correspondances et vous savez que je
prends l'exemple de limoges mais mort on
doit voir près la moitié des personnes
qui vont appareil qui rejoignent 40% des
personnes qui vont à paris qui
rejoignent des correspondances
internationale donc évidemment ce sujet
là le préserver donc c'est déjà un
aménagement ça mais c'est un aveu 10
rebonds importants le nom met d'accord
mais c'est le monde savait mais on ne
savait pas c'est ça que je veux dire et
moi je n'ai pas vu la rédaction exact de
la commande citoyens ce sujet en tout
cas l'engagement qu'a pris la france et
de sueur au tchad des lignes qui sont
actuellement destination de paris de
paris orly or les relations internes
leurs expériences manière à rattraper
les vols internationaux vous l'avez dit
une autre proposition de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat qui pourrait en
découler
on a besoin de vous occuper alors là
elle propose d'interdire la construction
nouvel aéroport ou l'extension
d'aéroport déjà existants se souvient ya
pas si longtemps de notre dame des
landes qui a été abandonné contre la
promesse d'agrandir nantes atlantique
est-ce que du coup ça n'aura pas lieu
d'abord c'est une proposition il ya un
sujet d'incertitudes sur la croissance
du trafic aérien
et on le voit on a déjà une dynamique de
reprise assez lentement à 30% des vols
par exemple pour la france qui sont
privés au mois de juillet
40% pour août mais aucun des
prévisionnistes ne prévoit un retour à
la normale avant 2023 2024 peut-être
aucun premier sujet qui effectivement a
trait aux capacités aéroportuaires futur
je pense notamment à certains terminaux
qu'il va construire en région parisienne
ou à d'autres extensions de capacité au
vu d'une trame une croissance du trafic
aérien qui probablement ne se réalisera
pas un mot n'est dit c'est que c'est
suspendu après le sujet donnant qu'un
sujet particulier parce que vous savez
que nantes pour le coup est un aéroport
en croissance qui est d'ores et déjà
atteint quasiment sa la saturation de sa
capacité donc il ya un processus qui est
lancé qui est toujours lancé de mise en
compétition pour le réaménagement sobre
de notre de nantes-atlantique pardon
sobre parce que nous avons vraiment
veiller à ce qu'il y ait une
consommation minimale du foncier à ce qu
il est un pur enjeu là n'est pas abrogé
la continue là pour être amendé ce
projet là n'est pas abordé ce projet en
l'état continue il est important pour
les nantais et encore une fois cela
renvoie je pense sur tous ces sujets à
la concertation de territoriales parce
qu'il n'ya aucune mesure générale
parisienne qui doit pouvoir s'appliquer
partout en france
donc ça c'est une invitation que vous ne
revenez pas en tout cas de la convention
citoyenne j'ai pas de la rotja pas juste
qu'il a peut-être aussi rapide et les
adaptations locales qui doivent ou qui
devrait être fait si tenté que ces
procédures podium un mode air france qui
envisage de supprimer huit à dix mille
emplois
il n'y a pas si longtemps après la crise
vous avez prêté sept milliards d'euros
l'état a prêté sept milliards d'euros à
air france est ce que vous saviez
quand vous avez prêté cet argent qu'il y
avait des suppressions d'emplois doivent
pas je voulais franchement je comprend
pas c'est logique qui consiste à mettre
ces deux chiffres en regard vers le
deuxième chiffre premiers chiffres celui
de
des emplois je ne confirme pas quand on
prête cette personne ne sait aujourd'hui
mais ce sera présenté aux syndicats au
conseil d'administration
j'étais heureux que ce soit mon âme et
j'y reviens je reviens et je crie
croyez-moi je détourne pas légion mais
d'abord on prête 7 milliards et la
france pour que pour que la compagnie
air france du reste comme d'autres
compagnies aériennes françaises que nous
avons soutenue de la même façon
survivent et donc ce faisant nous
sauvons quasiment cinquante mille
emplois nous sauverons 50000 emplois
une compagnie qui s'est effondré sur le
plan financier puisqu'elle a vu
quasiment 90 7% de son activité au pire
moment de la crise s'arrêtait dans
toutes les compagnies d'ailleurs toutes
les compagnies mondiales ont
virtuellement était en faillite pendant
cette période donc l'état soutient après
la réalité c'est que ni vous ni moi
savons dire demain ce que sera le
transport aérien at-il repartir
rapidement
est ce que les gens vont avoir envie de
se transporter de la même façon et jean
quris côté le saviez vous n'avez pas
demandé de contrepartie vous avez dit il
faut sauver air france donc on donne 7
milliards d'euros ont près de 7
milliards d'euros
mais si vous avez vous avez durablement
un trafic qui s'établit à 81% de 80 % de
ce qu'il était actuellement pratiqués si
vous avez par exemple airbus quand vous
avez un bus qui prévoit que son activité
industrielle va être de 40 % moins
importante pendant deux ans qu'elle
était avant ça entraîne forcément une
adaptation du modèle industriel du plan
industriel et après ça doit se faire et
c'est là je vraiment je réponds aux
questions pas se faire évidemment en
transparence avec les syndicats c'est
pas souvent socialement pardon ça c'est
pas le cas actuellement
les salles du louvre tout dans la presse
tout le monde les journalistes mettent
plein de chiffres dans la presse qui par
ailleurs ne sont pas tout à fait les
chiffres que moi je vous avez quoi comme
chiffres on a même le risque de non mais
moi vous avez seront présentés non mais
vous avez des chiffres mais c'est à dire
que vous avez pas les mêmes ce gym sont
en train de travailler par le groupe air
france klm
ils seront présentés à ceux qui sont les
premières concernées saluer les employés
et à dire leur syndicat et ça doit se
passer comme ça sans vous dire que
n'avait pas les reins jim mc - non mais
je sais que sinon c'est 20% des effets
confond tout parce qu'on confond tout on
confond parfois les accords des
performances que utiles les possibles
départs volontaires on confond les
efforts de production confronte ou dans
ces chiffres nous prenons les choses
étape par étape
laissons le dialogue social se dérouler
je pense qu'on doit ça aussi aux
salariés qui sont tous les jours
inquiète de voir plein de chiffres dans
la presse
et les choses se seront assez vite est
ce qu ont débattu en transparence une
dernière question parce qu'il ya des
aéroports de paris également dit oui
présidé par augustin de romanet qui
prévoit des ajustements pour l'emploi ce
sont ces mots là aussi il faut
s'attendre à des suppressions de postes
là encore je crois que dans l'article
que vous mentionnez le mot emplois
n'aime pas du tout été prononcé augustin
de romanet la fia mais augustin de
romanet a dit ce qui est une réalité
c'est que 50% du chiffre d'affaires de
l'épée 50% du chiffre d'affaires et paix
était autre qu à gauche ils déferlent à
l'épée été supprimée de 50 % et 50 %
cette année pour le dire clairement
c'est une réalité il a dit qu'il y
aurait donc une transformation
industrielle du groupe
aux vues possiblement et 10 ajustements
pour l'emploi elle a peut être été
justement pour l'emploi on verra si
c'est la fira je crois qu'il n'a pas
prononcé de l'emploi mais on vérifiera
bourbon est par ailleurs effectivement
il ya une réalité qui est celle qu'on
connaît 50% du chiffre aujourd'hui une
forme d'incertitude sur la reprise du
trafic sur les investissements futurs
et je crois que encore une fois les
choses se font en transparence et je
rappelle que l'état est actionnaire
majoritaire du groupe a nommé en clair
sous 10 est ce que cette logique il va y
avoir des suppressions d'emplois
finalement les temps mais l état aura
parfaitement son mot à dire le moment où
le plan industriel d'hz adp sera connue
pour faire face effectivement à son
avenir tels que il dans visage et nous
serons évidemment extrêmement attentif à
ce que l'emploi ne pâtissent pas à ce
que des plans le cas échéant de
transformation de formation soient mises
en oeuvre mais ya pas forcément
destruction un peu à d'abord il ya des
logiques démographique vous avez par
exemple chez air france très largement
des gens qui sont amenés à plutôt partir
en départ anticipé en plan de départs
volontaires les choses peut se faire
sans souffrance sociale en transparence
il faut pas toujours présente et les
fausses attentes des licenciés il faut
s'attendre à ça faut s'attendre à ça et
jugerait andrieu le rédacteur en chef me
dit qu'il n'a pas dix emplois fictifs
mais ça ne remédie des ajustements
contre comme les autres compagnies their
comme les compagnies there et anne
autrement dit des suppressions d'emplois
quand même à l'arrivée parce que c'est
des ajustements sur les programmes de
vols sur
l'appareil industriel sous les moins
d'investissements qu'il ya d'autres mais
y aura des suppressions d'emplois adp
quand même on l'a compris c'est votre
impôt autres interprétations j'ai
beaucoup vous avez que c'est logique
dans poitrine a coulé nord on est désolé
mais la crise est profonde je pense
qu'il faut vraiment le prendre ça
n'allait pas le monde
la crise elle est profonde et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment prendre le temps de
regarder les choses secteur par secteur
item paritaire et ne pas essayer d'être
les prévisionnistes non de week
end à nous n'est pas d'aujourd'hui ni
vous ni moi le savon dire ce que ce
vietnamien
merci brigitte il est largement temps
maintenant de laisser la place à nos
invités parlementaire
[Musique]
parce que dans audition publique il ya
deux parlementaires qui viennent
débattre avec vous alors en l'occurrence
donc mal type de panneau de les défier
jean raymond legault n'est sénateurs les
républicains on va commencer par matti
de panneau parce qu'une question très
précise sur le verrou bière bonjour
j'avais une question bonjour monsieur
secrétaire d'état j'avais une question
sur la ligne perpignan rungis donc qui
est qui était le dernier train de
climmer en france donc qui transportait
des fruits et des légumes
vous aviez promis monsieur le secrétaire
d'état le 30 octobre 2019 que vous
alliez prendre très rapidement des
mesures concrètes il avait été promis
par le gouvernement qu'une solution
allait être trouvée pour sauver cette
ligne perpignan réagit ce qui transporte
quatre cent mille tonnes de fruits et
légumes par an or vous avez
ostensiblement de menti puisque la
semaine dernière 33 wagons réfrigérés
ont été détruits et que depuis votre
première déclaration non seulement
neutre n'a pas roulé mais ces wagons ont
été détruits et la suppression de cette
ligne veut dire 25 mille camions en plus
par an soit 80 camions par jour ce qui
est évidemment une aberration écologique
social et économique puisqu'il suffisait
de 25 millions d'euros pour sauver cette
question comment expliquez vous cette
aberration alors madame panos et
apprécie beaucoup et vous êtes deux fois
1 précise la première fois sur les
vagues ont détruit qui n'existe pas ces
wagons ne sont pas détruits les 33
wagons dont vous faites état sont des
wagons dernier va ils ne sont pas
détruits ils ne sont pas utilisés ils
sont garés parce qu'actuellement il n'y
a pas d'activité pour eux et par
ailleurs ça renvoie au vétusté de ses
wagons du maire général dans le fret
ferroviaire qu'il faudrait très
largement médiatisé ce pourquoi nous
allons présenter un plan de modélisation
du fret ferroviaire le deuxième sujet
c'est que c'est peut-être plus qu une
imprécision
c'est un procès d'intention cette ligne
perpignan régissent le train des
primeurs il avait été reconstruit il
était prêt à partir début décembre il
est prêt à partir et d'ailleurs à
valenton j'avais l'occasion d'expliquer
à l'assemblée nationale est ailleurs il
se trouve qu'il a une grève
madame panneaux à compter du 5 décembre
une grève de deux mois et demi que par
ailleurs je crois vous avez soutenu au
nombre de partis politiques
donc si le train des primeurs
n'a pas redémarré c'est du fait des
effets de la grève est absolument pas et
absolument pas d'autre chose ce train il
est très peu étaient prêts à partir à
repartir de perpignan pour aller à
valenton et nous avions fait un travail
extraordinaire pour mettre les charger
puisque le sujet c'était de pouvoir
charger les trains autour de la table et
nous avions reconstruit l'offre donc
voilà maintenant deux fois maintenant
[Musique]
toutes les facilités de langage mais la
réalité c'est que ce train était prêt
reprise et la grèce alors justement par
partie et maintenant
et donc maintenant le sujet c'est
effectivement de faire repartir le fret
ferroviaire il ya plein de sujets et on
va pas faire un mais là en l'occurrence
le perpignan réagissait ce qui ne va
repartir
oui mais ça renvoie à la façon dont le
faire partir il faut le faire repartir
notre façon structurelle
aujourd'hui le bon train le bon mode de
train pour le papillon a juste c'est le
transport combiné en gros même des
conteneurs sur des wagons ça nécessite
de faire des travaux de réhabilitation
du des quais à rungis l'état a dit et
nous ferons que nous sommes prêts à
accompagner la modernisation dia pas le
calendrier pour le redémarrage ya un
calendrier de yakari de remettre au
démarrage du prêt du fret ferroviaire
nous avons un plan mais j'ai peur de moi
finir agissent exactement il n'y a pas
de quel ministre ici maintenant on est
dans une situation qui fait que soient
effectivement on retrouve une solution
temporaire
c'est que nous avions créé pour
descendre à répondre oui mais je vais
répondre parce que soit on veut une
solution temporaire t que celle que nous
avions créé en décembre réussi à
remettre en oeuvre en théorie en
décembre soit on ouvre une solution
structurelle moi je pense qu'il faut une
solution structurée et vous savez si
vous connaissiez la jsk aujourd'hui
lesquels ne sont pas en état pour
accueillir du transport combiné si nous
voulons faire du transport combiné et
notamment des oeuvres étant de lax faire
barcelone perpignan réagissent par
exemple envers ce qui est l'ambition de
ce gouvernement à voir des axes beaucoup
plus important beaucoup plus grand et
amener d'ailleurs beaucoup plus de
produits et donc du coup renforcé leur
pérennité longtemps nous allons nous
avons un à investir et de a lancé des
appels d'offres
je vous le dis nous avons beaucoup
d'ambition pour le fret ferroviaire
beaucoup d'ambitions pour cette ligne en
particulier elle est plus que symbolique
elle est aussi un peu politique et
industriel man il faut qu'elle fasse
sens il faut qu'à trouver un équilibre
économique l'instant le gouvernement à
dire demain va démarrer ou sais pas ce
que j'ai fait aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
dire que le barrage puisqu'une cherchons
une solution pérenne que ça nécessite
des investissements assez important
d'accord à 10 ans
ces tensions politiques invisible assez
importants sur le cas de rungis et moi
je n'accepte pas ces procès d'intention
bon que vous faites pas ce que je crois
qu'il soit là c'est dès qu elle va
maintenant rejoindre jean raymond
hugonnet parce que vous avez beaucoup
entendu j'aurais abandonné ce qu'a dit
le ministre tout à l'heure sur le
financement des transports en ile de
france et comme vous êtes élu de
l'essonne évidemment ça vous a intéressé
de près oui bonsoir monsieur le ministre
en tant que sénateur essonniens et donc
franciliens bien évidemment je suis très
intéressé alors juste petit une petite
remarque avant de poser la question
c'est que quand je vous entends dire que
le remboursement du passe navigo serait
un geste commercial celui je vous
apprécie d'ailleurs et j'apprécie la
façon dont vous modérer vos propos
notamment dans l'hémicycle au sénat mais
mais laissez moi juste vous dire que
c'est un geste social et que c'était
absolument pas un geste commercial et
qu'il faut il faudra compenser donc
quand valérie pécresse demande d
justement des compensations de recettes
s'agit pas d'autre chose et compensation
de recettes on a mélangé un petit peu
les chiffres chacun les siens mais pour
l'exercice 2001 on est à plus d'un
milliard effectivement alors que laurent
de saint martin propose aujourd'hui 425
millions d'euros
le compte n'y est pas mais alors que je
ne sais toujours pas je ne doute pas
qu'on va y parvenir je pose la question
maintenant ne pensez-vous pas venu
maintenant enfin le temps alors que la
région ile de france représente 20% de
la population française est ce qu'il ne
faut pas trouver une façon de gérer
spécifiquement quand même les relations
financières entre l'état et
ile-de-france mobilité pour arrêter
d'avoir ce retard en débit sur les
transports
les gens sont transportés vous le savez
puisque vous les fréquenter vous êtes au
courant de tout cela et puis j'ajoute
même si ce n'est pas exactement le
transport en ile-de-france mais j'espère
vous voir le 12 juillet 2013
devant la gare de brétigny sur orge
puisque les sept personnes vous avez
parlé de limoges tout à l'heure il faut
3h30 pour rallier limoges et des fois
perdre la vie puisqu'il ya sept
personnes qui ont perdu la vie et on
s'inclinera devant leur mémoire ce que
j'en ai à brétigny sur orge de leurs
hommages aux victimes de l'accident de
poid tennis
je vous y serez vous accepté
l'invitation il accepte l'invitation
évidemment c'est vrai vous y serez
certain moment c'est un moment je crois
de sinistre mémoire et et effectivement
ça renvoie d'ailleurs à tout une action
qui a été entreprise par les
gouvernements successifs
suite à cet accident pour me enfin pour
se rendre compte de l'état dans lequel
était le réseau et ça entraîne
d'ailleurs l'action que prolonger au
gouvernement depuis 2007 en réussissant
malgré sur place ce jour là massivement
sous sénateur m'a vite avec plaisir
c'est le carrosse voix sur la bo les
irisations maintenant des transports
nous défendre nous il vous dit que c'est
le monsieur le sénateur j'entends faut
moderniser maintenant deux mots d'abord
rebondi ce geste commercial moi je
qualifie en droit ce qui est
effectivement un remboursement que c'est
l'axé c'est ce sont des contrats qui
sont de notre ville de france mobilité
et les opérateurs et je qualifiais cette
veste en droit et par ian lauzon un
travail très précis avec les régions et
monsieur le sénateur a raison de
rappeler qu'il faut distinguer la
fiscalité des pertes de recettes nous
ferons ce travail de façon assidue de
façon transparente avec les régions et
sur la modernisation et sur la
modélisation je répond d'abord dire que
ne serait ce que 1 ne serait-ce que
cette année en tout cas pour cette
période
c'est sur la modernisation des
transports en commun et seulement des
transports collectifs c'est un milliard
3 camille l'état sur la modulation des
lignes que monsieur sénateurs connaît la
connais très bien je pourrais citer
quelques exemples
et puis nous avons ces travaux du grand
paris express qui sont pharaoniques plus
de 200 km de lignes nouvelles simplement
métro pour simplement prendre ces
chiffres là avec une opportunité
d'ailleurs de croissance de rayonnement
de la région ile de france de par ses
travaux pharaoniques je pense que la
région ile de france bénéficie
aujourd'hui pleinement des efforts de
modernisation notamment du réseau de
croissance ou en tout cas de capacités
nouvelles et ça renvoie un sujet en lien
avec les régions qui est aussi celui de
la modernisation des matériels roulants
et là aussi je crois que la région en
lien avec l'état aura un rôle important
à jouer parce que en dehors des voix en
dehors des capacités nouvelles il ya
évidemment confort des usagers des
passagers les nouvelles rames faire avec
une alors on va monter on va retrouver
ma tite panneau je vais vous demander
d'avoir des questions un peu rapide
parce qu'il faut qu'on retrouve un peu
de temps matip panneaux 22e question
elle porte sur le plan de relance
économique et l'automobile en
particulier
oui alors cessé des questions qu'on
compte déjà été un peu a évoqué avant
donc effectivement j'ai pu être rapide
mais pas tout à coup sûr le plan d'eau
automobile pas vraiment on en a parlé
oui tout à fait nous avons eu de cesse
de demander des conditionnalités
écologique et sociale oz qui était
donnée aux grandes entreprises et
malheureusement les patrons nous donne
raison et notamment le patron de renault
auquel l'état a accordé un prêt garanti
à la hauteur de 5 milliards et qui ferme
son site de choisy le roi qui est le
seul site en france qui fait une
économie circulaire qui reprend des
anciens moteurs et des anciennes boîtes
de vitesses et les remet à neuf alors
officiellement comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure ce n'est pas un plan de
licenciement il n'y aura pas de
licenciements licenciements secs
ils doivent partir à 70 kilomètres de là
donc on sait que les compétences des
salariés ne seront pas garder parce
qu'ils ne pourront pas aller à 70
kilomètres de chez eux car les salariés
ne sont pas des ménages à bhl comme des
objets donc c'est une crédibilité de
l'état et de l'argent public dont il est
question quand allez-vous et assumer
votre rôle de ministre
moi je veux vraiment pas être polémique
sur ces sujets je comprends parfaitement
ce que vous dites
et vous avez raison de dire que les
salariés ne sont pas délocalisables tout
ce qu' il faut traiter tout cela avec
beaucoup de doigté sur le plan social et
je crois que jean dominique senard quand
il dit nous ferons ce plan sans
souffrance sociale en accompagnant tous
les salariés dans leur capacité à se
former sur d'autres métiers sur d'autres
chaînes à être mobile quand cela est
possible je crois qu'il prend les choses
dans leur réalité la crise automobile
tel que nous l'avons vécu nécessité de
faire deux choses d'abord d'amortir la
crise tels que le secteur a subi de
façon extrêmement violente moins 90% de
de vente en immatriculations en avril ça
a été aussi très fort en mai il fallait
relancer la consommation ce que nous
avons fait avec les dispositifs assez
inédit prime à la conversion bonus
électrique notamment
est ce que vous dit la députée sarah
l'état n'intervient pas pour dire à
renault attend des as ne supprime ce
trader choix de ce point de vue là nous
avons réussi à relancer la consommation
je crois que deux en deux semaines c'est
plus de 36000 prime à la conversion par
exemple qui ont été activés et après si
on regarde un peu et qu'on des zooms de
faim si on essaie de se dire que ce
qu'on essaie de reconstruire maintenant
ce sont les avantages comparatifs
combien l'économie de dans deux ans dans
cinq ans dans 10 ans alors même que
cette industrie est mondialisée et très
concurrentiel et qu'on a des coûts des
constructeurs qui sont
extraordinairement bien organisée
hors de l'europe c'est ça qu'il faut
c'est de construire maintenant et ça
c'est tout le soutien que nous faisons
sur les véhicules électriques le
véhicule autonome le véhicule connecté
ça c'est créateur d'emplois ses
créateurs d'emplois qui d'ailleurs sont
relocalisées en france pour certains ou
savait que psa a pris l'engagement de
relocaliser beaucoup de ces emplois pour
construire le véhicule hybride
rechargeable et voyez c'est l'emploi
pérenne
c'est à la fois l'industrie
d'aujourd'hui et même l'ex jury
américaine avec l'argent public français
notamment parce qu'elles soient et
cohérent dit que vous voulez que toyota
groupe français avait à valenciennes
retourne au japon c'est ça que vous
dites oui pour l'activité
vous financez des eaux financer des
groupes américains qui viennent vendre
en france des véhicules qui viennent
créer parfois de l'emploi en france donc
il faut 10 à nous ce que nous voulons
dit gamme airbus devait faire un projet
de développement en france et que avec
l'argent public il a reçu puisque et à
15 milliards pour l'année à
l'aéronautique a décidé de finalement
donné le marché sans aucune condition
même en 2008 qu'ils ont mis pour parler
d'un autre sujet mais on va pas y aller
sur le sujet parce qu'on n'a pas le
temps on va pas y aller mais vous allez
voir parce que c'est lié avait ce que va
vous demander jean reno et donner tout à
l'heure parce que voudriez revenir sur
le statut
enfin la position d'aéroports de paris
oui alors moi je pose la question de ce
ministre est brièvement naisy pensez
vous ne pensez pas quand même un peu
baroque
à l'heure où l'état pense à privatiser
adp ce qui est parfaitement scandaleux à
mon sens d'être encore au capital d'air
france qui fait encore l'état à hauteur
de 14 3% si ma mémoire est bonne voila
voila ca france et souvent vous
trouverez vous reproche le contraire là
c'est pourquoi pas privatiser totalement
d'abord je pense qu'effectivement le
sujet pour la france aujourd'hui c'est
davantage sa capacité à résister et à
redevenir conquérant dans pourquoi ne
pas privatiser totalement air france est
ce que vous demandez coville
orco vise bien ce web et sur un an mais
il ne vous a pas échappé que l'année
dernière en février mémoire on a eu une
montée au capital de l'état néerlandais
à hauteur de 14% sur fond de discussions
sur la gouvernance à france klm
nous allons résoudre sujet par sujet en
tout cas difficulté par difficulté moi
je m'en a d'ailleurs aux pays bas après
demain notamment sur ces sujets mais pas
que donc d'abord résoudre le sujet de la
gouvernance du groupe air france klm
séparait toujours en débat il ya un
groupe de travail en rien une bercy sur
le sujet et après effectivement on peut
tout à fait se poser la question de
savoir quelles sont la place des états
dans le groupe ce qu'ils ont comme
projet stratégie et place de l'état
français la place pardon de l'état
français pourrait diminuer au cours d'un
doute mais j'ai cru comprendre quand
même ce que dans la séquence la demande
était davantage ce que l'état mais ça
c'est la demande mais qu'est ce qui
serait souhaitable
moi je pense que l'état comme
actionnaire dans des entreprises qui
sont stratégiques comme air france ou
alors pour soutenir des activités qui le
sont un peu gros pour un pouce et entend
un moment où en fait de façon très
intéressante seulement un peu
planificateur avec avec notamment sur
les romantiques nous un prix est allé au
bout de votre vous avez commencé une
phrase oui justement de l'étranger par
exemple j'essaie de jeu résume en une
phrase ce qu'un tout petit peu de moi et
je suis désolé sur les idées et on passe
un je pense que l'état a tout à fait son
rôle pour être actionnaire et impulser
des actions dans les secteurs
stratégiques je pense que l'avion d'air
france par exemple l'avion du futur par
exemple construit l'avion du futur
ça nécessite d'investir énormément
aujourd'hui pour construire l'avion de
dans 12 ans qui sera possiblement
hydrogène et qui sera un avantage
comparatif industrielle pour la france
et possiblement un avion d'exploitation
pour iphone hervé ans mais pour air
france fait elle même la société air
france et donc moi je dis que prendront
les choses dans l'ordre
on a un sujet de gouvernance avec les
néerlandais qui sont au capital d'air
france klm au même niveau que nous il
faut clarifier leur position aux abords
ce sujet de gouvernance et après la
caisse d'un blog qu'est ce qui bloque ce
qui bloque c'est des exigences en termes
de gouvernance réciproques dans les
différentes entités du groupe
néerlandais en veulent trop des sons
volontariste dix ans sur le sujet voilà
défendre d'être d'accord je vous demande
vraiment de poser votre question en 20
secondes
la dernière concernant la publicité oui
il ya eu un rapport paru récemment de
greenpeace de résistance à l'agression
publicitaire et de régions action climat
qui vous appelle à interdire la
publicité sur le secteur automobile le
secteur aérien et
les transports maritimes donc sur les
transports les plus polluants notamment
les suv le transport aérien
il nous l'avons proposé plusieurs fois à
l'émission ça a toujours été refusée
pourquoi n'êtes vous pas favorable à
l'interdiction de ces puits merci pour
cette réponse cette question rapide
voilà la réponse sera aussi très rapide
nous avons voté et vous avez ôté or
peut-être pas mettre dans la loi
mobilité saturn de mesures qui est par
exemple pour la pub pour les pubs
automobiles font valoir les autres modes
de transport le covoiturage etc
le malus automobile notamment pour les
suv prend en compte cette dimension là
est donc un site ainsi très fortement
les français à se détourner de modèles
qui aujourd'hui sont mais pas question
d'interdire la publicité mais je crois
vraiment hors frais qu'on ait ce débat
n'a pas en trois secondes parce que non
mais parce que c'est un sujet important
mais moi moi vous voyez je interdire les
pubs pour l'automobile le maritime la
gestion ça renvoie au type de modèle que
vous voulez moi je pense que vous voulez
des modèles qui ne sont pas nos choix de
société qui sont des modèles de
décroissance d'un certain nombre de
modes de transport je ne suis pas sûr de
vouloir que l'avion de mon point de vue
sur rejoint trifi que seuls les riches
comme dans les années 60 puisse prendre
l'avion oui ça envoie des modèles ce
texan différent parce que moi je crois
que le fait se déplacer de rencontrer
d'autres cultures participe de la
pacification des peuples il ya droit que
vous défendez un modèle décroissants qui
alors à mon sens n'est pas un modèle
fouta pour la france alors question très
rapide aussi de jean-raymond eu des
réponses rapides concernant les
autoroutes
oui ma question concerne les concessions
d'autoroutes monsieur le ministre comme
vous allez certainement surnager au
remaniement c'est tout le mal que je
vous souhaite est ce que vous serez le
ministre qui va enfin remettre autour de
la table des concessionnaires pour
rediscuter de ce ratage qui a été la
privatisation des autoroutes porté
d'ailleurs par la même personne qui
porte réalisation d'un dpe monsieur le
maire à l'époque où il était alors voilà
deux cabinets seule question c'est que
vous allez remettre tout le monde autour
de la table pour arrêter ce racket et
cette faillite finances jean baptiste
geiler et je vous laisse je réponds en
deux points très rapide mais bon si
comme député j'avais porté une
proposition qui s'intéressait à la fin
des concessions à l'avenir des
concessions qui comme vous savez pour la
plupart arrivent à échéance entre 31 et
36 j'ai fait des propositions notamment
de retour dans le giron de l'état avec
tout un système de
de meilleurs contrôles de meilleure
régulation de ces concessions sur un
sujet sur le sujet polémique de la
rentabilité j'observe quand même des
choses on a souvent dit les concessions
autoroutières sont sur rentables sont
très rentables ça a été documentée à
plusieurs reprises mais on a souvent dit
qu'il n'avait qu'elle ne courait aucun
risque c'était de la rentabilité sans
contrepartie
or aujourd'hui le risque s'est réalisée
puisque vous avez qu'elle porte le
risque de trafic etc avec le co vide
l'effondrement du trafic et donc des
péages on va fait que les concessions
autoroutières ont perdu plusieurs
milliards d'euros donc je veux dire que
on pourra voir ce débat tout à fait
apaisée mais que le discours qui
consistait à dire on a de la suivante
habilité face à un risque qui ne se
réalisent jamais été fortement contredit
par les faits aujourd'hui mais juste
hummer ravine sociaux n'attendons pas de
bal avec vous et donc cdpa spécule de
noront a bien merci jean raymond legault
des mercis mathilde de panneaux d'avoir
posez vos questions à jean baptiste
djebbari on va accueillir maintenant
yves thréard du figaro
bonsoir bonsoir francis bonsoir jean
baptiste djebbari me suis très bien
alors c'est de nouveaux chemins
l'écologie c'est ça c'est ça le nouveau
chemin que nous avait tracée
je crois que c'est pas un président de
la ve république c'est pas un nouveau
chemin peut-être une amplification de
l'action nécessaire mais moi je n'oublie
pas tout ce que nous avons fait j'ai été
député et encore pas si longtemps et je
ne le vois que nous avons arrêté des
projets qui étaient réputés comme
écologiquement
ils ont rencontré pas les exigences
environnementales que nous avions le
prix de la montagne d'or et projet de
notre-dame-des-landes récemment le
projet d'europe a city je voulais pas
que nous avons engagé un mouvement
majeur pour le verdissement des
transports pour une voiture bio à la
cantine ne lui pas un risque ce que nous
avons fait et ce dont nous sommes fiers
en tant que majorité parlementaire à
risque parce que vous avez utilisé un
mot tout à l'heure qui a adapté dans mon
oreille dit la décroissance on y va
plaindre situeront si on n'y sera pas on
est mal revenir à paarl le temps de
travail réduit qui a été abandonné leur
est bon on va vivre comme au moyen-age
bientôt non je voulais les tueries fait
enfin les promoteurs de la décroissance
vont voir ce que c'est la décroissance
les croissance s'est un peu maintenant
parce que quand vous avez un pib qui
chute de 10% de 11%
vous avez évidemment des conséquences et
conséquences économiques des
conséquences sociales donc pour ceux qui
avaient un doute sur le fait que la
décroissance n'est pas un avenir
souhaitable je crois qu'ils seront très
largement démenties par les faits et je
le dis encore une fois l'état a fait
tout ce qui était possible pour amortir
les effets de la crise pour revenir très
rapidement à l'équilibré et promettre en
tout cas mettre en oeuvre une croissance
qui soit respectueuse de la corde qui
soit une croissance et avec ce que nous
proposent nos citoyens là les 150
citoyens
bah on va se retrouver tout seul sur ce
banc de la décroissance au milieu de
l'europe parce que les autres ils vont
pas faire ces choix là donc ça dépend
d'abord il ya les mesures effectivement
il ya beaucoup de propositions fiscales
oui oui et on est déjà les champions du
monde à la fiscalité oui donc moi je
sous les longs relais c'est on va
laisser le débat se faire moi y ait des
mesures que je trouve intéressant dans
les propositions de construit après la
tva à 5,5 sur le train il ya des mesures
km heure j'y revenais 7 millions ou
spécial mais il ya des mesures qui sont
intéressantes et puis effectivement il
ya beaucoup de fiscalité alors qui ce
qui est porté par un talent a commencé
aussitôt elle moi je pense qu'il faut
avoir un débat tout à fait
apaisé sur le sujet et soumettre
peut-être à l'appréciation du peuple
français savait qu'en france et
l'insertion des passionnés sur un
certain nombre de mesures qui veut
pourrait redessiner ou en tout cas
participer à redessiner ce qu'est ce
qu'il est convenu d'appeler le le monde
d'après un référent des questions à
refaire il est question d'un référendum
est-ce que deux choses 1 est-ce que
c'est pas un peu si vous me permettez
l'expression risqué voire casse-gueule
d'organiser un référendum d'ici à la
présidentielle qui a lieu dans 18 mois
première chose deuxième chose ce
référendum s'il a lieu il aura lieu en
avant la fin de l'année l'a alors sur le
livret du camp je n'en sais rien et
présenter un public supprimera
probablement au lendemain des
municipales voilà quand le lendemain il
a dit en tout cas rencontré la
convention ah oui c'est qu'on vienne le
29 on n'est pas dit quand il s'offre
quand il sait pas si le 29 le jour
d'après ou plus tard mais bref j'imagine
qu'il s'exprimera ne serait ce que pour
retracer les perspectives comme il s'y
est engagé dans son accord cette année
alors que jean présidentielle rapinât
james yeux c'est qu'on a pris l'habitude
que le référendum soit des objets qui ne
vise plus à améliorer la vie des
français mais à débattre la légitimité
du pouvoir en place
eh ben je me suis demandé yves c'est un
risque je crois que je crois que c'est
une déviance
si oui mais c'est un risque politique il
existe alors là la convention fait des
propositions très concrètes qu'on peut
juger positivement ou négativement des
séismes ils vont juger le président mais
les français ils ont ensuite vos envies
je pense et nous envie qu'on s'occupe de
leur vie quotidienne
pour le coup les propositions elles
soient extrêmement concrètes y compris
derrière des propositions qu'on peut
contester sur plan politique
philosophique bon mais elles sont
extrêmement concrètes et touchent à la
vie quotidienne se déplacer se nourrir
produire consommer et donc j'imagine que
ces propositions elles sont faites dans
l'esprit de faire avancer la france dans
le monde de demain et que ceux qui vont
et français qui seraient amenés à se
rendre aux urnes ne vont pas voir
derrière chaque but à la tête d'
emmanuel macron mais bon bien voter sur
les propositions c'est ce que vous êtes
malgré tout mais je pense que ce sera le
cas je pense qu'on a été très largement
contredit par les événements par les
cris d'anaïs politique depuis des mois
et des mois nous mais il des choses qui
ne se réalise pas un paradoxe donc moi
je pense que ce référendum s'il existe
un paradoxe vous dis consistera à nox à
répondre à des questions réellement
posée d'accord il ya un paradoxe quand
même on est dans ces élections
municipales
on voit que ici et là vous vous alliez
souvent avec l'est républicain contre la
gauche
or et bien vous présenter actuellement
vous êtes dans une réflexion sur
l'écologie et on voit que ceux qui
tirent les marrons du feu dans cette
scrutin ce sont précisément les
écologistes alors et vous vous alliez
pas avec les écologistes vous alliez
avec les républicains moi je constate
que quand on regarde les alliances de la
gauche et des écologistes ce sont en
général les alliances assez radicale
avec la france insoumise les remakes
n'est pas égal à bons amis avec des
écologistes avec des membres
d'extinction en millions avec des
politiques des propositions politiques
qui portent des modèles parfois qui
confiait à des croissances moi je pense
qu'il faut absolument clarifier les
projets sous jacent à ces propositions
électorales et j'observe bien souvent
que les propositions qui sont faites et
c'est parfaitement le choix de ceux qui
les portent elles sont souvent très
radicale possiblement décroissante
elles ne correspondent pas au monde
écologiquement vertueux que nous voulons
porter pour demain donc nous sommes tout
à fait fondée avant à défendre des
valeurs politiques qui visent une
écologique soit n'est que logique on
arrête qui mène des qui dit que c'est
pas logique quand même parce que lui il
a poussé un coup de gueule
vous connaissez j'ai jugé lui nation et
il dit mais c'est pas normal il aurait
dû s'allier avec des écologistes plutôt
que s'allier avec des républicains
mais c'est son avis je ne partage pas
j'ai partagé beaucoup de choses avec
monsieur cohn-bendit le camp je ne
partage pas son appréciation et je crois
que le mouvement est fondée ils se
trompent dit ce qu'il veut il se trompe
dans son endroit de j'ai le droit de
penser qu'ils se trompent absolument ce
qu'il veut je pense qu'on est fondée
tous les écologistes sont des affreux
jusqu'au boutiste ans ils veulent pas du
tout mais je pense qu'en plus ces fins
cette époque où je dis différemment
aujourd'hui tout le monde parle
d'écologie l'écologie je crois a été
conscientiser par tout le monde
notamment par la jeunesse - choix que
j'ai fait partie d'une génération qui a
été très mal et vers l'écologie
né au milieu des années 80 avec une
société hyper consumériste il fallait
avoir deux paires de nike et trois
tee-shirts plus que silver atena je
pense que j'étais mal élevé je pense que
là la génération d'aujourd'hui est
beaucoup plus et c'est très bien
conscient de ces enjeux là et donc
l'écologie elle transcende assez
largement les vieux clivages politiques
et que personne peut se veut sans
revendiquer absolument par contre il à
différents types d'écologie et je le dis
encore l'écologie décroissance qui
considère par exemple comment
baho que la conquête de l'espace n'est
pas un acte des progrès qu'on doit
effectivement virer au tout localisme
que se déplaçait c'est mal je pense que
c'était écologie là ne ressemble pas
investi ce que vous savez qu'il ya un
problème au vu des statuts beaucoup
contestent la présence de certaines
statues en france à lille ce week end le
général faidherbe
j'en ai parlé à martine aubry qui m'a
dit d'un an et hors de question de
toucher à faidherbe
il peut y avoir un yacht hey soul a donc
des gens qui sont souvent associées à la
conquête colonisatrice de la france en
afrique
est ce que vous vous vous recevez le
message de ceux qui contestent et même
de ceux qui voudraient voir déboulonner
sa statue
je veux c'est de faire une réponse
simple et rapide mais si on commence à
rechercher dans l'histoire de france
les personnages parfait pure qui n'ont
jamais été le fruit de leur temps alors
vous déboulonner tout le monde vous
enlevez le nom de jules ferry qui par
ailleurs a été un personnage important
pour la france et qui je crois a fait
bien plus qui apporte bien plus à son
crédit qu'à son début
mais vous dirais qu'il a été un
communicateur ou en tout cas un soutien
de la colonisation française de l'empiré
français et donc voulu déboulonner je
crois que l'histoire et d'un bloc avec
ses parts d'ombrés avec ses réussites
ses succès achevé parfois c'est c'est
ses difficultés et son finir dit rien et
je crois qu'il faut assumer tout ça d'un
bloc ça empêche pas d'avoir une vision
extrêmement lucide c'est un homme lucide
sur notre histoire actuelle sur ce qu'on
veut construire pour la suite et que
l'histoire du passé y compris d'ailleurs
le fait d'honorer des mémoires qui sont
oubliés ou qui ne font qu ils
bénéficient pas de statut me paraît être
une façon beaucoup plus positive bien
revisiter notre passé et de se projeter
vers l'avenir bien merci hiver s'il une
dernière question en ce moment il ya des
vtc qui manifestent rue de rivoli à
paris qui est réservée aux vélos et aux
taxis des vtc n'y ont pas accès vous
trouvez ça normal
nous avons eu beaucoup de discussions
avec les buts et ce notamment pour les
inclura mais là sur la rue de rivoli à
paris
et effectivement et qui sait pas droit
bon c'est une décision et socialement de
la mairie de paris pour des conditions
les conditions que vous connaissez bien
nous avons beaucoup travaillé de
l'urètre il faut qu'il y ait égalité de
traitement entre taxis et vtc là vous
aurez un sujet qui nous ne s'y serait
plus de ports de plus de 30 secondes je
vais devenir un rodez bas très bas on va
recommencer
merci merci jebbari c'est la sphère
l'audition publique merci d'avoir que
c'était débattent de répondre à nos
questions qui étaient nombreuses
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur figaro l'afrique sur
les comptes twitter de cp public sénat
et auditions publiques revient lundi
évidemment en direct à 19h
[Musique]